COUNTRIES ADMINISTEF
THE VACSD SN B D'SUPPLIER.ROLET
NEXT I O OF VACCINES?
>> Reporter: MATTER O DAYS,
HALA, A FEW D WILL
OUT CCINES.F THE COUNTRIES LIKY
ARE T
RNO
NO MASND HUGS.
LE ALL AGERONGET T VACCINES.
HEREYA AND IN OTHER
COUNTRIES CONTT,
ISIF REALI
THIS WAS TCENE AT
NATIONALPI FEWS AG CONSTAN OF PI
THIVINGE TUNTRY'
PRECIOUS LASTTS I IIKRIGHT.OS A9
VACCINN Y
EYPE
AND DON'T KNOW WHEN THEY'LL BE .
KENYA RELDLOAX WITH I ITS OWN CY
EXPOS. IMP BEING A COVAX DEPENDT
NA. TO RUN OOFAC IN AR DAYS.SY
CARE NAIROBI
CAN'TIND ONEOFFERING VACCINES.
>>ep TSERATELYARCHING FOR A F
BE AWAY.
A MOTHER TWO DOESN'TCE.
E TEL S HAS BEEN
EVERY MAJOHO IN THE
CITY.
SHE I TRYING SMALLERIN
LOSING FRIEND  COV9ING CE HAVI
RT IMMUNI
I AM FOODTABLE, HOME.
S TO GET
JAWEEK THEVE PUSHEDK  DOSES BYR
HADST ONE, BUT WOUO ONE WHEN TN
WAGER DOSE.
>>or WORLD HCINE RISK OPENGS TM
HE SCIENTISTS,
THAFRES THENDSTH IAN WITHURHE
INDIHA HN
FORHE WHOLE WORLD
TR  SON,  M SOMETHINGNOT DONE.A
>> YOU HAVE TO GIVGE SUPERREADER
ADAVE
VACCINATIS FOR
SUVAAN VILLAGE. OF U
ARE.MS
IS BEING LEFSISTENT WHAT
WON'TSTAY INFRICA. THETLA NADMA
P HIGH OF
TENS OFHO AIN
A D B DOWN TO A FEWND OR A DAYA
PRO